[Music]
imagine that this is the beginning of
the last thing you will ever see
an empty landscape with thin lines
scratched across it but those lines
suddenly sharpen and gather into a dense
mass that spreads from the crown that
sits atop a giant studded with greens
and yellows a giant that is in search of
one thing
food
and then imagine that you are the food
tiny in the face of this alien whose
body is designed to take you in and
break you down and as it retracts
pulling away from the scenery you
disappear with it
we're letting magnification and music do
a lot of the heavy lifting when it comes
to setting the scene up close this
animal is upsetting its movements slow
until they are sudden peaceful until
they are predatory but from further away
things are a little different it looks
strange but it seems less overwhelming
than before it seems just kind of chill
even as this other large organism
brushes by the animal we've been focused
on belongs to the genus kaluthica making
it one of our favorite types of animals
a rotifer and we've happened upon many
rotifer mishaps and Adventures in the
microcosmos before they're always being
bullied or eaten or caught up in some
tragic tale of their own making but in
the case of the kelotica their biggest
bullies might be themselves because
these organisms love to eat even if it
means eating each other
foreign
are put in an awkward position when it
comes to seeking out food because they
can't easily hunt it down most galithico
species are sessile which means that
they don't really swim around instead
they spend most of their lives stuck
attaching themselves to whatever is in
their vicinity and seems like it might
be a good home like the ones you see
here and while they're there the
coloticos surround themselves in a
gelatinous tube giving them a sort of
squishy sleeping bag that they could
retract into when something disturbs
them and it turns out it's very easy to
disturb them those long threads we saw
at the beginning of this video aren't
just decoration they are there to help
the rotifers sense the world around them
both so they can recognize danger and so
that they can find food the hairs are
called cilia and we've seen them on
rotifers before in fact they are a
defining feature part of the inspiration
for the name rotifer which translates to
wheelbearer it it's the fast spinning
whirling motion of the Cilia that gives
the head of the rotifer its wheelie
appearance but while cilia are
noticeable on all rotifers they are
particularly long and noticeable on the
collothika and they also seem to be
extremely sensitive James our master of
microscopes has found that if he is
recording kolothika he has to be extra
careful to not walk around the
microscope if he does walk the
vibrations and his steps reach the
collothika and drive them to retract
into their gelatinous safety vest like
other rotifers collothika appear to be
able to use their cilia to create
currents that draw food into their
mouths whether it's algae or some other
kind of single-celled organism or even a
tiny crustacean like a water flea the
colothika probably doesn't care as long
as it gets fed it uses its enormous
mouth to close in on whatever it is
eating wrapping it up and the Bony
called the trophy and then swallowing
its prey and a jerky motion based on
what James has observed he's been
starting to suspect something kind of
funny about how kalothika get their food
because sometimes you'll see smaller
organisms just swim right into their
mouths so James thinks they may be
getting a little extra help that when
the collothika retracts into itself it's
actually pushing a little bit of the
stuff in its stomach into its giant
mouth and in that regurgitated mass are
nutrients that could be attracting
single-celled organisms toward the
rotifer now we're not sure if that's
what's happening that the rotifer is
puking into its own mouth to lure in
more food but if it is true it's still
not the weirdest way that koluthica gets
a meal that would probably be the
cannibalism but not just any form of
cannibalism will do for the collothica
it is specifically a baby cannibal fully
willing to eat its own child
cannibalism is a striking behavior for
collothika but not necessarily A
surprising one in the same study where
this Behavior was documented another
non-colothica rotifer was observed
engaging in sexual cannibalism where the
female rotifer would eat the male
rotiver after mating was completed that
behavior is not unheard of in the animal
kingdom where insects and spiders can
often turn their last mate into their
next meal it's not actually clear if
koluthica do the same thing to their
male counterparts in fact for a long
time it wasn't even clear that they had
male counterparts we've known about
golothica for more than a century but
the first malcolothica wasn't observed
until 1986 and it turns out that male
koluthica were generally smaller and
most importantly their lifespans were
super short on the order of 20 hours it
is as if they were born just to breed
and then die soon after but we're
getting away from our original topic the
cannibalism the captions from the paper
documenting this actually tell the story
quite succinctly from panel a female
neonate emerging from gelatinous tube
from panels B to D adult female
ingesting female neonate
it's simple it's a little poignant and
it is tragic for that female neonate
it's also unclear to us how common this
behavior is or isn't and why the rotifer
mother might engage in it it does not
seem to be a great way to pass on your
genes perhaps it was just in need of a
nutritious snack perhaps it was a
mistake perhaps in the microcosmos
rotifers can't be choosers
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and thank you
especially to these people here on the
screen right now they are our patrons on
patreon they make it possible for us to
continue to explore this really bizarre
and beautiful world and to make
observations that we can't yet confirm
but hopefully someday we will be able to
like that rotifers maybe puke in their
own mouths to attract food if you like
what we do here you can go to
patreon.com journey to micro if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram or Tick
Tock and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
foreign
[Music]